grave faces the red sox for the first
time so a bit of a disgust discovery
process for him and the boston
and schwarber hitters this one to right
and that's off the wall
schwarber just missed another in this
ballpark and he dives headlong with a
double
so there's two on for the sox here in
the first
red sox can't let this chance go by they
got to take advantage of this
stays home at third
and this could be two mercer escobar
four six three close at first
field and culprit the crew chief made
the out call
[Applause]
tanner hauck starting for the first time
in more than two weeks
yeah it's been a while since we've seen
him start a ball game kind of gotten
used to him coming out of the bullpen
house one two yes oh he got him swinging
with a beauty
[Applause]
two-two
got him swinging and it's back-to-back
caves with the slider for tanner how
and a roller towards short that's devers
in the shift and a one two three for
taylor hauck in the first
strike
recall
yeah guys are definitely having trouble
on both sides seeing the slider right
now
and i'm reaching here comes escobar
glove transfer perfect
alex 1-2
he got him looking
how about that with a split finger
running away from bell yeah let's split
bait on the corner two down here in the
bottom of the second inning no score in
the game andrew stevenson starting in
left field for the second straight game
how about that wow he gets tied up on a
slider and on a drop third strike
stevenson reaches this ball hit him it
hit him so if it hits him he's out right
here's the call out strikeout dead ball
and hernandez drives one to the other
gap and elaine thomas looking right into
the sun
will run it down remember josiah gray
seven in a row retire
swing gonna miss on the slider
that's number three
two down here in the fourth and now
here's raffy who grounded into that loud
double play to end the opening frame
he lands on a 2-2 fastball driven by
devers right center field to the wall
and that is god
rafael devers right on cue and the red
sox take the lead in the fourth
one two
swinging a
yeah so the sliders still working in the
shadows
1-2
elevated at 95 for strikeout number six
[Applause]
alps 2-2 to soto is strike three called
seven k's in four perfect innings for
tanner howe
now a swing and a miss behind a slider
and down goes renfro on strikes
outside gray with his fifth strike out
of the game two out nobody on here at
the top of the fifth
stevenson
can of corn from the top shelf
one two three for gray in the fifth
halfway through the game
good due-ups and that's down by a run
bell bounces one right side [ __ ] on the
grass on the backhand throws out bell
one away
rolled the second again
and kiki hernandez has been busy and
there's two down
one two
there you go caught on and missed and
tanner houck is perfect through five
with eight strikeouts
this was tanner hauck coming off the
mound going down the tunnel and his
dayek is done unbelievable what a game
for him and he was absolutely perfect to
say the least five perfect innings
no hits no walks obviously eight
strikeouts 53 pitches cora went down and
then hugs in the dugout oh unbelievable
you talk about 53 pitches through five
innings eight strikeouts the most he's
had in his career in any game
swing
and a miss
number six
for josiah gray
yeah took the fastball up high enough
to make it unreachable that may be what
he had in mind for denver's two innings
ago or just throw by him either way
works
hernandez flips bogarts is there and
three ground ball outs for garrett
richards in the sixth
swing and a miss austin both
cutting one that ended up well outside
eighth strikeout by washington pitching
today
right down the middle
austin both one of his best innings
another 2-2 from brazier and he got him
swinging
went to the slider to strike out soto
[Applause]
target away 2-2 to bell up the middle
pretty well placed
and he'll beat it out
that was well played by bogart's out of
the shift
tap her right side and the race is on
the ball
was dropped
by brazier and the bases are loaded with
two down jordy mercer the batter
brazier's 2-2
he got him looking brazier walks the
tightrope in the seventh
yeah davey can't go out there and save
him and he's gone
right on the outside edge
got it splitting it right under his back
two down
three straight walks worked by the red
sox and they are loaded for debras
[Applause]
swing and a miss
a no contact eighth inning
with three strikeouts and three walks
out of he knows 02.
ran the fastball to the edge for strike
three called and there's one away how
about that little comeback fastball in
the outside corner
and this one popped to center up into
the twilight redfer didn't see it right
away and ryan zimmerman's hustling in
the second
safe
bases loaded bottom of the eighth one
nothing gave one out and juan soto
a chance to cause chaos everywhere
soto center field
didn't get it ryan zimmerman scores
it'll tie the game
just missed the grand slam
[Applause]
so it brings up christian vasquez basket
good fastball hitter it's a ball the
other way and he does hit a fastball the
other way soto retreats he can't make
the catch
and the red sox leaves you want a big
hit or what and here's shaw another run
would look huge now 1-1
shaw tags one left center field and that
drops down in front of bell vasquez can
skip on home and the red sox add
insurance [ __ ] hernandez it was one
fifth
well if you're going to start to breathe
you really got to take a deep breath now
this is a beautiful thing
so now andrew stevenson comes up
and that ball is hit well
deep left center tailing flying
see
you
later
the nets have taken the deficit and just
like that cut it in half and the nats
are down to one out remaining with ryan
zimmerman
who
just took it
and ryan zimmerman is on again for lane
thomas that's a big league at bat right
there zimmerman has drawn a walk
bringing the tying run to the plate
oh two
popped him up
shallow right center
and renfro takes charge in the red sox
win
5-3 the final and they pull even with
the yankees you win tomorrow and you
will host the wild card game